[Captioned via Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're making some rubber knuckles.
Proto putty in a shape that looks
kind of like brass knuckles,
but in reality, will act
more as a punch protector
than any sort of weapon.
[Music]
A while back, Grant showed how
to take some foam core sheets
from the dollar store,
and cast them in brass
to make these functional brass knuckles.
There's the spikeless version
and the spiked version.
Frankly, there's very few situations
where you'd actually need these,
and you really shouldn't ever use them
because that's a dangerous weapon.
However today, what we're going
to be doing is looking
at how to create something
quite similar to this,
but using soft Proto putty.
You can wear them
on your hands.
They can feel kind of
like brass knuckles,
but in the end, they're going
to be more cushion than weapon.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got a couple
of pieces of wood.
We're going to cut the negative shape
out of one of them,
glue it down to another board,
and use some Proto putty pressed into
the gap to make a rubber set of knuckles.
To start out, we printed off
these styrofoam knuckles template
that we used before,
and we're going to be
cutting this shape out,
tracing it onto a piece of wood,
and then cutting this out on a scroll saw.
[Music]
We've got the basic
shape cut out.
Let's use a little bit
of spray adhesive over the back,
then stick it down to our board
so we can trace it.
I cut this little divot out,
but that was an attachment
for one of the spikes,
and I don't think I'm going to use that.
So that's just going
to get trimmed off as well.
[Music]
This is our basic shape.
While we've got that down though,
let's cut out these circles,
and also attach those onto the board
so we know where that's going to go to.
The circles won't actually
have to be lined up perfectly.
This whole piece is going
to get removed from the board,
and we're just going to
have a hole that shape.
That will get glued down
onto another board, and all
of the Proto putty will get pressed in.
So we are going to have
to cut those circles out,
but we can actually just cut those shapes
out of any part of the board,
and then glue them in,
but we'll just trace them on
so we know where they go.
We've got the shape,
and that's where we need
to cut out of the board.
We've got some very intricate turn
around little loop spots,
and that's why we're going
to be using a scroll saw.
Scroll saws have
a very fine blade.
They're really good
for tight little corners.
We also want to cut just
out of this piece here,
and we don't want to have
to cut a line into there.
So we're going to start
by drilling a hole,
and that's what we'll use
as sort of our access point.
We'll then thread our saw blade
through that hole,
attach it onto the saw,
and cut everything from there.
[Music]
We've got our negative.
This will get attached
to that board, and now,
we need to cut these five pieces out,
and attach them in there as well.
[Music]
Not bad, not bad.
We've got our five pieces.
And now, we need to glue
everything down in place.
Before we do that though,
I am just going to take
a little bit of sandpaper,
smooth out those edges in there,
and just try to make them a little nicer.
[Music]
Let's use some glue, attach these,
maybe add some clamps.
Just hold it on place,
then we should have
our rubber knuckle mold.
[Music]
I'm gonna try and
make two colors at once rather
than a single colored punch protector.
I'm going to try and
have sort of a marbled effect
by mixing two colors.
I'm not going to mix them
some so thoroughly,
it becomes one color again.
I'm just going to try
and get two colors all swirled together.
[Music]
Use a ventilated area
for Proto putty.
It gets intense.
[Music]
Random fact:
John L. Sullivan, the last ever
bare-knuckle boxing champion,
once fought a 75 round fight
which lasted over two hours.
[Music]
Well, I made
a little bit of extra.
You can see I've got some
that didn't get used,
but I got enough.
Better to have too much
than too little,
because patching more
on there would have been annoying.
So now we just have to let this cure,
and I do have this extra piece
as a sample.
So I'll know that
once this one's ready,
that one should be ready.
I think our Proto
putty has cured.
Let's see if we
can pop this out.
[Music]
We lost one of our finger holes, which,
I mean it'll be easy to attach back down.
It just popped off.
Probably could have made
it easier to get everything out
if I had angled everything.
Like sanded it at more of an angle,
or something like that.
But I want to be able
to use the same molds
for both the left and right hands,
and so, I just had
to leave it straight up
and down, which makes it
so it does grip quite a bit.
[Music]
There is our first one.
It was a little tricky to get out,
but it did come out.
Fit our fingers
through the holes.
That worked pretty great.
It's actually does a pretty
good job of padding.
I would not want to punch something
that hard without something on my hand,
but it's just kind of bouncy.
Let's make another one.
[Music]
Our mold worked great.
We've got two sets
of rubber knuckles,
our Proto putty punch protecting knuckles.
These are really not going
to do a darn thing
about making you punch harder.
But what they are going to do
is kind of protect your fingers
if you are punching something.
Now, I'm not a doctor.
I'm not a boxer.
I'm not an expert who
can tell you that like,
Oh , yeah. These are great for...
What they're good for is looking
like brass knuckles,
but not having to worry about injuring
yourself or someone else as much.
Not saying you should punch people
with the rubber knuckles on.
You'll hurt them,
you might hurt yourself,
but it's just kind of fun.
They look cool.
Anything cool you would like to see
us try making out of Proto putty,
let us know down in the comments.
We're always looking
for some good ideas.
Guys, time for some
questions and answers.
You asked the questions.
We're giving you answers.
Sir Spork @CaptainSpork3 asks,
how do we come up with ideas
for our videos?
Sir Spork, that's...
That's an interesting question.
So when I joined the channel,
Grant had already been coming up
with ideas for years and years.
He had seven years worth
of ideas just put onto a list,
and when I applied to be his assistant
on the channel, I submitted my own list
of about 80 ideas,
and it was really just sitting down,
and thinking of what are some things
that I think would be cool to build,
or some experiments that I think I
would like to try.
I literally just sat down and thought,
what would be a good thing to build?
What would be a cool
experiment to try out?
And some of those, I tried,
and they didn't really work out.
I've had some experiments where
I tried them, and there
was like no cool result whatsoever,
and I was like, well that's really dumb,
and not exciting at all.
But we do keep trying
to come up with things.
We think what
would be fun to build?
What would be fun
to experiment with?
What have we never
seen anyone else do?
Or what's a weird way
to use a material that
everyone's familiar with,
that we could present in
an entirely different direction.
I think those ones are pretty fun
because there's all sorts of things
we interact with daily
that we don't think
of other uses for them as much,
and that's one of my favorite ways
to come up with ideas is to take
something that we use regularly
and use it irregularly.
Thank you, Sir Spork
for question.
Guys, thanks for watching,
but the fun does not end here.
That box up at the top
will transport you to our last video,
and you should go check that one out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you're not yet a subscriber,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way, you'll never
miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.